[Music]
sister and laurie asks what happened on
1888 in reference to the general
conference
and how is it connected to our time
from october 17 to november 4 i believe
was this very famous general conference
session in minneapolis
not too far well in the midwest you know
where that is
and um
it is well known for
the teaching of wagner and jones
righteousness by faith
it also is known for some controversy
prior to the conference there was a
bible institute a bible class that ran
for about seven and a half days from the
10th to the 17th and there was some
heated argument about
you know the horns
of daniel 7 what nations actually are
represented by the horns and it was an
argument between 80 jones and uriah
smith uh swift was a recognized expert
on prophecy anyway so that preceded the
actual general conference when the
conference began the controversy then
became righteousness by faith taught by
jones and wagner and uh
after the conference people looked back
and they wrote books and they summarized
and they
some said well the church accepted the
truth others said the church rejected it
uh so you have this back and forth eloi
writes very copiously about the fact
that the truth was not fully accepted
and i had the church taking the message
and everyone had done what he or she
should have done the whole message would
have gone to the whole world she makes
that very very clear
um
we look back on that now i mean i need
to ask ourselves
what is our condition today
are we
leodycine
in verity or do we learn from our past
we learn from our past rejection of
truth as some believe occurred in 1888
can we accept the truth that el white
said god gave to these two men
now while what the man said is not
exactly written down but we can glean
what they teach from what ellen white
wrote in the books after 88 steps to
christ desire of jesus christ object
lessons thoughts about the blessing and
ministry of healing those five books she
wrote after the 88 session and you could
see what was taught by what she wrote
because what she writes is far more
authoritative than what jones and wagner
said even though she said they had
credentials from god but they were not
profits as she was
and so we need to make sure that we are
in harmony with the truth as god has
laid it out clearly in his word and made
it very very clear in the writings of
his servant evan white and i urge
everyone listening to me to make a
decision to read steps to christ
microscopically we desire of ages reach
christ's object lessons thoughts on the
amount of blessing at least those four
books of course ministry of healing but
the first four especially steps to
christ i believe that came first
then desire of ages then i think christ
subject lessons thoughts amount of
blessing read those four books if you
want to understand uh
righteousness by faith justification by
faith obedience through faith
so we need to measure ourselves
are we consistent with the plainly
spoken word of god as he is laid out in
his word and made very clear to us
almost with kindergarten simplicity in
the writings of why and i urge you again
all those listening read steps to christ
microscopically
read it along with the bible passages on
which it deals and also
the desire of ages
amen see people don't change people
don't change because truth is truth and
the carnal nature is the carnal nature
the carnal nature is what it is from
adam until now truth is what it is from
god until now the carnal nature does not
like truth it has no problem with church
it has a problem with truth and so we
need to make sure that we're in harmony
with truth and the central teaching of
the bible is justification by faith what
god does for you and in you
he does for you when he justifies you he
does in you with your cooperation when
you live a righteous life day today
which is called sanctification the
central teaching of the bible is
justification or righteousness by faith
amen amen thank you all the skeet
righteousness by faith yes because no
person can save himself or herself no
matter who you are you cannot save
yourself if that were the case calvary
was a waste of time waste of blood you
cannot save yourself you can have 10
phds in theology you cannot save
yourself you can be a direct descendant
of enoch and elijah and moses who live
in heaven right now you cannot save
yourself
you may have wings you cannot save
yourself and so there is something
christ must do for you and in you but on
both of those for you and in you
requires your cooperation
amen
and one thing i would like to be found
rejecting truth let us not be found
rejecting truth the several days the
sabbath that's biblical and there's
nothing in the bible that changes that
there's nothing outside that changes
what the bible says the seventh day is
the sabbath
i like to harp on that because it's the
key issue
and
it the seventh day is the sabbath
jesus is fully divine
except that if he is less than divine he
cannot save you
because only god can save from sin so
jesus must be defined
any being less than god cannot save you
only god can save you and so and i don't
want to go on and on and on but
matthew 1 21 thou shalt call his name
jesus for he shall save his people from
these sins matthew 1 23 call him
emmanuel meaning god with us only god
can save
don't reject that truth don't make
christ less than god he is fully divine
and don't make the holy spirit less than
divine because he it is that convicts
you of sin and the bible is clear you
you you blaspheme christ there's
forgiveness you're blessing the holy
spirit there's none so you've got to
uh
align yourself with these fundamental
bible truths you're saved by christ who
is fully divine you're convicted by the
spirit that's fully divine you're
accepted in the beloved by god the
father of course who is fully divine and
that the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god and the pope cannot
change it your iman cannot change it
your prophet cannot change it your
whomever cannot change it
the city you accept the truth the better
it is for you and those around you
you need to carry on like that but
i said it there it is amen next question